or when the actual numbers were released
yesterday about job losses but what's
the ripple effect that can be seen in
the economy overall well we're seeing
what we're seeing is the worst recession
of possibly since World War two
certainly since the early 1980s that is
meaning a lot of things that means a
much more difficult environment for
workers of all stripes even people who
still have a job which is still let me
think ninety to ninety two point four
percent of the labor force even people
who still have a job have less
flexibility to change jobs they have
less negotiating strength to negotiate a
higher wage you know where we're
experiencing a very deep downturn and
it's not clear that that's gonna end
anytime soon
so eight point one percent as we're
seeing it isn't the number that will
stay on for a while then it's hard to
imagine that we will the way these
things work is the labor market tends to
lag other parts of the economy so it's
it's you know hard to imagine that that
this thing will stabilize in the labor
market and the job market anytime soon
when it's clear that the u.s. is still
in a pretty deep recession that
consumption is still shrinking the GDP
is going to be down perhaps six or seven
percent even in the first few months of
the year and and unfortunately that's
kind of what we're we're stuck with for
at least the next few months in a
general sense what areas of the labor
market were most affected by these new
numbers manufacturing as it has been
throughout this recession throughout
this downturn lost a lot of jobs so did
construction we've seen this broaden
though the only fields that actually
gain jobs in February were they were
health and health care and education and
government basically everything else cut
jobs retail leisure and hospitality
information kinds of jobs financial
services all of these areas that at one
time were kind of keeping the economy
afloat these service areas are not doing
it anymore one of the lines in your
story this morning say it says that
economists are now calling in a question
whether the intricate suite of policies
crafted by Congress the Obama
administration and the Federal Reserve
are bold enough to deal with the scope
of economic damage can you expand on
that yeah what what's happened
throughout this recession throughout
this downturn is that the government's
done a lot of stuff if you remember
going back to 2007 the Federal Reserve
was already cutting rates the
the the Bush administration was was
taking some steps to try and help
homeowners and try and stabilize the
financial system
there was a stimulus bill passed a year
ago if you remember we just had this
giant stimulus bill there was there was
one that was much smaller those past
last February the the the truth is that
every step of the way though things that
the government thought were proactive in
getting ahead of the problem have been
too small and too too narrow it's you
know the government has been behind the
curve for for 18 months running as this
downturn has you know as this financial
crisis has blossomed and as this economy
has gone into recession and you know
even though we have a very large
stimulus bill that was just passed a
couple weeks ago it's not clear that
it's not clear that would be enough to
to cushion the entire brunt of the
standards of the economy's facing and so
where does this leave the administration
as far as tools to use well they still
have things being deployed and they and
they urge patience they say you know we
give us give us a little time the you
know they have a financial rescue that's
moving forward they're doing stress
tests of major banks major institutions
they have this mortgage for reduction
plan to try and help people who are at
risk of foreclosure and of course you
know they would urge some patience on on
the stimulus itself that's nearly eight
hundred billion dollars all that you
know the question is how bad will the
economy look by the time we get to the
point where these things start to kick
in and will they be powerful enough and
meaningful enough when you know we could
well have a ten percent unemployment
rate by by summer or fall it's very
plausible and if that's the case will we
have enough of a government response in
in the pipeline to to deal with it well
the public give the president the
patience that he's looking for they say
they will if you look at polls they say
that they're patient and and realize
this won't be fixed overnight it'll be
interesting to see whether that's the
case assuming if we do indeed get to a
ten percent unemployment rate in the
second half of the year and and it's
still you know stimulus is still
trickling out will will people you know
he has a very high approval rating now
will that will that continue and I don't
pretend to know knew or when our guest
for the next twenty five minutes if you
want to ask questions related to the
economy and policy decisions by this
administration on the economy 202 737
triple zero to four Democrats 202 737
triple zero
one for Republicans and independents 202
6 to 8 0 to 0-5 newer when we were
representative John Campbell was asked
during a hearing on this about the
message that was found in the numbers
that will came from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics want you to listen to what he
had to say and respond to it you
mentioned now that we've had three
months in a row of job losses in the 600
thousands it based on you're looking at
history or the trends in these things
is there any silver lining there that
perhaps the job losses have stopped at
least accelerating or is there perhaps
any history that would say gee you can
bounce along the bottom here for an
extended period of time or what is there
any message from that probably not a
good message it's it's it's easy to sort
of think of these numbers as being
relatively stable but you remember it's
a stable loss it's it's a you know
losing over 600,000 jobs a month is as
very significant and just to put it in
perspective we've only had maybe 10
months where we've lost 500,000 jobs or
more in the history of our series since
1940 this is four of the ten all in a
row miss Darwin it's true and I would
note that when you have kind of very
serious sober minded people telling you
that things are really bad things are
really bad I mean there's no way to put
up put a nice gloss on this thing you
know the economy requires about about
200,000 jobs a month just to indentation
just to keep up with population growth
even in some really bad months if you
remember right after 9/11 there were you
know a ton of layoffs and the that was
still when the.com bust was happening
there were ton of layoffs in the hotel
and airline industries that month right
after 9/11 we only lost about 300,000
jobs and now we're losing 600,000 a
month every month and that's just not a
good situation for American workers
Mendon Massachusetts you're up first
good morning thank you you're on go
ahead okay I want to say I think that
job losses because of Obama
I don't think they should bail out any
any company Fannie Mae or any of those
places when you say the job losses are
because of the president what do you
mean by that what do I mean by that I
think we haven't had job losses like
this and forever but I think because of
all the things he's trying to put
through to bail out these Pape places
they're well why don't we just just
won't leave it there Thanks
I I'm not sure I'd buy that the idea
that all these bailouts and rescues are
the reason for the job losses is
probably not what's going on what seems
to be happening is we have the popping
of a giant credit bubble in a giant
housing bubble the financial system is
in disrepair if anything all these
rescues and bailouts you can criticize a
lot about the details of how they've
been executed but these are things that
are keeping the the recession in the
downturn from being worse than it is
it's hard to imagine that if they had
not taken over Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac for example which the bush
administration did or if if the
government had not taken over AIG as
again the Bush administration did in
September or put money government
government money into banks hard to
imagine that the economy would be
significantly better off if they had not
taken those steps I heard this morning
on the radio that numbers for November
December had to be revised that's right
the government goes back and every month
and takes you know has more and more
data to decide what what the results
were and that was actually one of the
more shocking and more negative parts of
yesterday's report is the December and
January numbers which were already
pretty bad were were even worse than
originally thought Little Rock Arkansas
on our Democrats line go ahead yes I
wonder who I want to ask mr. Lee
why do the Lydia most of the mainstream
media and the writers why do they only
report the negative things about this
economy they don't report deposits just
like that Northern Trust Bank that had
the party they returning that money as
paying is returning his money for that
elaborate bathroom
you know and the people in Chicago they
lost their job at that plant they're
being rehired they got their severance
pay somebody else took over the company
and they're good they gonna be rehired
you know report some of the positive
things just happening don't we try and
report the truth we try and report
what's what's going on in the world and
explain that in a clear and honest way
and the truth is if you look at all the
big picture numbers if you look at how
most Americans are living right now it
is the economy is not in good shape it's
it's again it's the worst recession
certainly since the early 80s possibly
since the 1930s and I bury strongly
believe that to to state otherwise would
be would be lying would be misleading
our readers and so and so that's why we
we report on all this bad news and the
truth is some individual situations
where people are better off or being
helped is not the same as the overall
unemployment rate rising to 8.1 percent
which is the highest since 1983 and and
if we focused on some individual once
you know individual negative positive
things we might miss the fact that this
is an overall not a good economy how is
consumer spending right now it's weak it
has does not seem to be getting weaker
this first couple months of the year so
there's a big fall off in the fall and
the winter going into the Christmas
season
it appears that consumer spending seems
to be stabilizing a little bit
tentatively at a at a low level that's
that's a positive sign you know it's not
a strong sign but it's it's certainly
not a negative sign if if that holds up
and consumers just hold where they are
on spending and consumption then then
perhaps some of these forecasts the
economy will stabilize and turn around
at the end of this year or the beginning
of 2010 those might hold up if if
consumers indeed stop stop their
contraction I guess and what's the
relation between consumer spending and
consumer confidence it's it's more
tentative than people think
consumer confidence is is very very low
people are not at all confident about
the economy in about the future
according to the surveys the historical
relationship between how people will say
they feel in a survey and what they
actually do when they get to the mall is
not as precise as you might imagine
so what's happening is people are very
much lacked confidence and they're not
spending a lot of money but they're not
pulling back the way they were a couple
months ago and so maybe big-ticket items
get reconsidered and those kind of not
quite yet auto sales are still very very
bad durable goods so washing machines
and you know anything that lasts more
than three years sales of furniture that
sort of thing are still very weak that
said they're not getting much weaker
than they were at the end of the year so
you know how does that how do you count
that is stabilizing at a low level
positive or negative that's it's
somewhere in between I guess Mueller
when our guest Philadelphia Pennsylvania
and our next call Neil thanks for coming
this morning how are you good thank you
listen I got a comment for American then
I got I want to go through the
public-private partnership for the bank
bailout with you America get every dime
and the stock market out before this
plan is announced
Neil well it's going to be we are the
America is going to give $9 hedge funds
and the SATs are gonna put in a dollar
that'll make ten Dow
correct is that the idea they're gonna
lever my pendant not necessarily to that
degree but but yeah the government will
win money to lever up hedge fund
investment yep okay okay now where are
they gonna get that money from they talk
about money on the sidelines boom you
know where this money's gonna come from
it's going to come from the stock market
and it's gonna crush everybody stock
values if you think about it I mean
let's face it they're gonna guarantees
they're gonna loan money how sweet is
that they're gonna they're gonna
guarantee the kind of this thing I think
that if I was one of these folks I'd be
getting every be taken back pop bottles
begin to that program what the caller's
talking about is well they're two
separate things and what the
government's trying to do in their
attempt to rescue the banks and to get a
lot of these toxic assets off of the
books of banks is create a public
private investment fund and the way this
would work is investors such as hedge
funds or private equity funds put in
money the government loans them more
money so they that's what we mean by
lever op you you borrow money and and
and have more total money to invest and
that fund would then buy assets such as
mortgage assets out of the books of
banks so
banks that have too much of this stuff
on their books nobody's quite sure what
it's worth these funds would buy that
stuff and hope you know the idea is to
take that risk away from banks so the
banks are you know have some sense of
their future and can start lending again
there's there's a lot of technical
challenges to making it work and the
government's going to have a real task
on hand to try and execute that people
over the Treasury Department or are
working hard on that probably as we
speak they've been working a lot of
weekends lately and you know how exactly
that is executed and and what the impact
is on the financial system and in the
broader markets I don't think anybody
knows for sure just yet have they figure
out how to value these stocks because
that's one of those questions that
constantly gets asked well that's that's
actually why they're doing this this
joint thing with the private sector the
idea is that the government you know
government bureaucrats aren't terribly
good at saying this asset is worth X and
so we're and we're gonna pay for the
odds that the government would either
over pay or under pay or are quite high
that's why they're doing this joint
arrangement with private investors and
the idea is that the private investors
who that's their businesses buying
assets will be better able to figure out
what the stuffs worth and decide what to
pay and the government just lends them
money and then you know assuming the
investors make good decisions the
government gets paid back and gets its
money back and and if there is a loss
and the investor takes the first loss
and the government only loses if if the
investor makes a really bad decision
another discussion is tax rates and the
future of tax rates a Mayor Bloomberg of
New York was on his radio show yesterday
and talked about these things
particularly what he called the rich tax
he said this he said the protean
protesters clamoring for increased taxes
on earning $250,000 and more had to be
aware of the new economic reality quo we
can tax the rich except that if you
haven't looked at the stock market
lately they aren't making any money he
says how would you could you add to that
it's it's true you know that the truth
is where it's it's we're in a deep
recession it's affecting everybody this
is one that that is not just affecting a
narrow slice of of the country you have
certainly you know lower-income people
construction workers any kind of service
worker people like that or hurting but
so are so are the influence or wealthy
people you know look at all the layoffs
on Wall Street look at all the
job cuts and you know law firms and you
know big big employers to pay people
people a lot of money are also cutting
back that said you know the the idea
that a couple years from now if you look
at the Obama budget that you will see
tax increases on you know relative to
where they've been the last several
years on on upper income people it's it
looks like that's where the momentum is
in Washington Tacoma Arkansas Republican
line good morning it's Tacoma Washington
thanks for taking my call
we can't just be a service economy and I
was wondering what you think about
bringing all the service jobs that have
been shipped out for credit and banks
back to the United States plus all our
machine tool out of Japan and
manufacturing like the auto industry
bringing that all back to the United
States instead of shipping all of our
manufacturing and agricultural power to
China why don't we bring it back here
and fix our economy it's a it's a little
more complicated than that than saying
that manufacturing in America is is in
bad shape
what's what's happened in the last
couple of decades is it's certainly true
that there are a lot fewer manufacturing
jobs you know the manufacturing workers
are have lost jobs and and shifted into
other sectors that said the amount of
stuff we actually make has risen what's
happened as productivity has gone up a
lot in the manufacturing sector so you
know fewer workers are able to make more
stuff than they did 10 or 20 years ago
that said is you know is is is there
some weakness in our manufacturing base
right now there absolutely is no
question the Atlanta
journal-constitution had a map yesterday
showing the changes in the unemployment
rate those sections in blue are those
hardest hits followed by those in well
actually those sections of red hard to
say followed by blue and then brown a
lot towards the coasts not so much
towards the the the middle of the
country
well that that map looking at it kind of
mirrors where housing prices got most
out of out of whack with with
fundamentals so Florida California
Arizona Nevada some parts of the
Northeast these are places where
there was a very large housing bubble
that is now either popped or in the
process of popping depending on your
view and and so that is a major factor
and people in those places not wanting
to buy anything those local industry is
being devastated and and you know if you
look at the unemployment rate in Florida
or California right now it's extremely
high has anybody predicted a bubble as
far as housing is concerned or at least
a bottom I guess as far as housing is
concerned that's one of the big
questions where is the bottom and are we
there are we almost there you know the
truth is even a lot of the problems in
the financial system in the banking
sector are tied to not knowing the
answer to that question so if you're a
bank and you have a mortgage loan and
you think the person might default if
the if the housing prices drop another
20% then that's worth one number and if
it's if we're at the bottom for example
then then that mortgage is worth more
and so it's hard to value that when you
don't know how housing is going to
bottom out and the truth is the
government's doing a lot of things to
try and try and improve the situation in
the housing market the Federal Reserve
is buying half a trillion dollars worth
of mortgage-backed securities to lower
mortgage rates the government's you know
there's an $8,000 tax credit in the in
the new stimulus bill to try to
encourage people to buy a house will
that be enough to stabilize prices I'm
not sure we had a we had a an epic
run-up in prices in the first part of
this decade and and now a remarkable
decline and where exactly bottoms out I
don't I don't pretend to know you have a
beach ha Hawaii go ahead good morning
and thank you for having me on that's in
Hawaii by the way which is a blue state
buggy enough to not be in that situation
but this is sort of I am living with HIV
say 18 years I'm an optometrist and I am
now disabled man and I work as AI under
a 501 C 3 taking care of people living
with HIV and AIDS hepatitis and
substance abuse so the past few years
I've been trying to get the legislature
because we are a medical cannabis state
to allow us to
distribute medical cannabis for free and
not another tax stamp but to charge a
fee for processing and dispensing at my
lowest cost that I figured out a patient
would pay eighty two dollars a month or
a quarter of what the federal government
the federal government by the way thinks
that it takes six point six five towns
of medical cannabis to keep the
chronically ill patient comfortable
they've been running a study for 30
years
whatever university why if I prove it to
my legislature that I believe them nine
thousand dollars for a task force I'll
facilitate your task force I have I have
legislators behind me why hmm is the
federal government and I hope that they
will not allowing the state to that are
giving medical cannabis to patients to
do exactly what I'm asking develop I
just have to leave it there I don't know
we could pass on Wylie Texas go ahead
why why isn't the government looking at
other way the same way Reagan turned
around the double-digit unemployment
republic representative bachman on
c-span had ideas that it can immediately
turn around the country below sees new
taxes are going to kill us all she
doesn't care she when you said President
Reagan's philosophy do you mean tax cuts
yes she has I watch c-span and she had
them all is it that each one that would
immediately turn this around and
nobody's listening they've got but Losey
steamrolling us to hell well keep in
mind it the Reagan boom you know
certainly the early eighties tax cuts
played a role another really important
role in the in the boom under the Reagan
administration was that the Federal
Reserve had really risen interest rates
very high in the in the Carter years in
the late seventies early eighties to try
and stop inflation remember the
inflation of the 70s they push rates
very very high to stop inflation and
caused the deepest recession of the
post-war era
it caused a unemployment rate went to
believe ten point eight percent in 1982
which was very painful very difficult
time but then once inflation was stopped
and they they finally whipped inflation
the Fed cut interest rates back down to
a normal level and that's what that's
that was a major factor in the economic
economic expansion began in in eighty
two eighty three and lasted through
through the Reagan years that's not to
say that tax cuts not helped that that
expansion Tim Geithner what's his
performance to date so far as far as the
economy is concerned Tim Geithner of
course the new Treasury secretary he
he's gotten some mixed reviews and and
and probably more negative reviews than
positive the the challenge they're
trying to do is they're trying to lay
out an overarching framework for the
financial rescue there was a feeling
that the former Treasury secretary
Paulson was skipped around too much he
seemed to jolt from one from one
strategy to the next on the financial
rescue so the the Obama people are
trying to have a more systematic
overarching strategy that said in the
you know what months six weeks they've
been in office conditions have just
continued to deteriorate very sharply in
financial markets around the world and
and it's not clear whether the markets
in the in the financial world have the
patience to to wait for this kind of
systematic overarching approach it may
be that trying to be systematic means
that means that they're moving too slow
and then looking at everything what's
the first sign that things are turning
around
is it housing is it jobs are there other
factors well there's there's there's two
sides there's the financial side and and
the truth is we won't have a a real and
lasting economic recovery until and
unless we have a bottoming out in a and
a stabilization of the financial system
you need you need the flow of credit to
happen you need you know your banks to
be to be functioning and not zombie
banks
you need you need all those things to
work before you can have a real economic
expansion now there are some signs the
financial system is more stable than it
was certainly in November
banks are lending to each other normal
rates some you know companies can issue
debt a little better than they could a
month or two ago that said this this
last two weeks there's been you know
stock market has dropped sharply all
kinds of more obscure indicators of how
markets are functioning or worse so it's
not clear where they're yet on the
financial side Tucson Arizona go ahead
please good morning and thank you for
c-span I I I know all about the housing
bust and everything but the job loss
mainly is ever since when during the
campaign trail I mean ever pretty much
everyone knew he was going to win but
when it came up that the taxes were
going to be raised and you know the rich
were going to be taxed nervous that's
when I started seeing people just all
around me losing jobs people started
tightening their belts that means all
the all the there's all the owners of
all these businesses everybody said oh
god we're going to get hit you know so
there everybody's tightening their belts
people stopped my husband's a printer
people stopped coming in to get print
jobs people I mean he's cut down to
where he has to take a day or two off
unpaid a month which has really hurt us
and it's just you know he's had to move
to another shop I mean he's in the works
for the same company but moved to
another shop because you know they're
scaling down on everything and in one
month you saw like 10 people get laid
off this is not a huge huge business but
it's big enough that it makes a big
difference and it's just you see what's
going on I watch c-span I watch the news
and you just see Obama is not paying
attention that's what everybody sees I
don't know he's just even he's not even
gonna go near it until they pass
something about the health care well you
know what screw the health care get this
taken care of you know at least cut
capital gains more just cut to cut them
out put put glass people back in you
know do something do it Jesus it's just
ridiculous
well they're doing a lot of stuff I I'm
not sure what I mean you know they're
not doing a capital gains tax cut but
they are you know the stimulus bill does
cut taxes for for most lower to middle
wage Americans it does you know they are
spending the government is spending
eight hundred billion dollars to try and
to try and fix this thing and there's
the financial system rescue that's going
you know that's investing a lot of money
in banks and trying to stabilize the
financial system you have a seventy-five
billion dollar program to try and help
people at risk of losing their homes to
foreclosure I would get on the broader
point of you know is this is this thing
Obama's fault because he's talked about
tax tax cuts you know economists like to
say correlation is not causation it is
true that the economy got a lot worse
and kind of fell off a cliff back in
September October when which was also
when Obama kind of rose in the polls and
looked like he was going to win but
there were other things happening then
and and what was happening is Wall
Street was completely melting down
Lehman Brothers went bankrupt the
government had to take over AIG Fannie
and Freddie were nationalized there was
a you know once once a century storm on
Wall Street's and in the financial
sector III I think all the evidence is
that that is the reason we are now in
this deep recession not not expectations
that Obama was going to be elected one
more call Shelby Township Michigan
hey good morning gentlemen yeah people
just don't remember back in 2000 before
the Supreme Court put the oil industry
in the White House Elgar warned
everybody about George Bush's economic
policy he said he's going to build a
bridge to the 1920s and George Bush blew
it off you know what's just fuzzy math
and all the little draft-dodging rich
kids like you know Bill O'Reilly and
Rush lebara laughter I'll think it was
real funny in their brain dead people
that listen to him just went along with
it this
it's not so funny anymore you got this
dude over on River Road him whatever his
name is who wakes out on the the market
floor talking about oh I hope his
neighbor's out
yeah I'd much rather they have people
foreclosed Romney and lose $100,000 and
the value of my house didn't have to pay
a few bucks into
helping somebody else I just there's so
much wrong with everything that's going
out of this country
you got the Republicans saying they
never got a chance to really be a
stimulus package and they tore it apart
for two weeks Republicans in the Senate
they revised the whole thing and now
they're saying they never got a chance
to read it and the brain-dead people to
rush the bar and go Riley saying oh they
never got a chance to read it they never
got a chance to read it you know as
people trying to assess blame for this
situation we're in that there's a lot of
it to go around and and a good chunk of
it belongs on on Wall Street with you
know the people who created this
financial crisis and made the very bad
decisions that got us into this
there's certainly blame to go around in
Washington and you know there's real
doubts about whether whether the Bush
administration was sufficiently
attentive to to financial regulation to
to those issues that said that goes back
to the Clinton years - and you know that
Bill Clinton also reappointed Alan
Greenspan the Fed Chairman Bill Clinton
and his administration Bob Rubin the
Treasury Secretary Larry Summers was now
back in high office they you know they
they had the same basic framework of how
to regulate the financial system that
that contributed I'm not going to say
cause but certainly contributed to the
situation we're in now you can see the
work of new or went on the Washington
Post website that's washe post com and
if you want to link to our c-span
website misterben thanks for your time
thanks Pedro we'll take a look at
proposals by the administration on
charitable